tonight County's controversial hand
counting of ballots has now come to a
halt at least for now but while it was
underway the eight news now
investigators were the only local
television station to witness that
process Vanessa Murphy has more from Nye
County
we came here to Nye County to see the
process of counting the votes by hand no
outside cameras or recording are allowed
inside but what we witnessed a tedious
process with some human error in the two
rooms where we observed though
volunteers went back to fix mistakes our
first date was a little rough as you
could imagine you know but today things
are going very smooth
much fewer recounts we interviewed Nye
County Clerk Mark comp on Thursday just
hours before the hand counting was shut
down the Secretary of State sent this
letter stating it must cease immediately
after a decision from the Nevada Supreme
Court that the process violated orders
prohibiting the early release of voting
results the ACLU had filed a motion
arguing observers could access results
when we observed yes we heard some
results volunteers are in groups of of
five an announcer reads the result a
person next to them verifies and taliers
record votes do you 100 agree with this
process
oh I 100 agree with this process and so
do the majority of people in this
community if final results are different
the group goes back for that specific
candidate to read
to
recess
25 ballots I observed four were
mismatched and then fixed how will you
double triple check the process
well of course you're aware that we are
using the electronic tabulation machines
as our primary method of determining the
vote the Dominion machines are working
Kelly Fitzpatrick is the chair of the
Nye County Democratic Central Committee
I view this is silly I view this as
being
um
still being worried about the big lie in
March the Nye County Commission asked
the clerk then to implement paper
ballots she later resigned comp who had
previously said Trump won the 2020
election then took over you have been
criticized for saying there's voter
fraud without evidence of it you are the
leader here can you address that
if you were talking to me as candidate
Mark conf we might have that discussion
but as Clerk I am responsible for a
impartiality in everything I do as Clerk
so what happened what my opinions are
have nothing to do with my functioning
in this job as an eye County Clerk but
you have such a huge responsibility and
if you were pushing something that there
was no evidence of
why should people trust you
they should trust the process we tried
speaking with some volunteers on camera
but they declined reporting in Pahrump
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now